you got vaccinated and you feel
very strongly about telling people that
you got vaccinated and getting the word
out that they need to get vaccinated why
don't you tell us about that
well i did that because you know black i
get it especially
for black people and uh people of color
that's a little skeptical
about getting the vaccine but we need to
get this and get it done
especially here in atlanta like i said
we have more black people in atlanta
than anywhere in the world
so i went and got to vaccination and
it's just important
because we've had a lot of mistrust with
the uh medical
community and the government yes and so
that's why it's my job to get out and
promote and
i got my first shot and i had no no
reactions whatsoever
i i uh i got to shot i sat there for 15
minutes
and i'm good and i'm ready to get the
second one as soon as possible
and uh if you if it's possible when
johnson johnson comes out with the uh
only one injection that's really good to
get now johnson johnson the black people
should have no
problem with that that's johnson and
johnson that's a black company
that's one of the great black companies
of all time of all time
you're the black and decker well one of
them was black seals and robot
back in the day robot was black you've
never heard about but
george i gotta say you are unselfish
you are on you are on fire you uh you're
on fire
uh you know quarantine has not slowed
you down
uh one second i am honored to have you
on the show
i'm glad you i'm glad you got over your
conan bias uh and decided to give us a
shot
you still you're still gonna get it
you're still gonna get it but you can
get this book at george wallace.com
yes george wallace.net i didn't go to
amazon because they take happy money
this time i thought let me make all the
money because i
be thinking
all right so that's right go to uh you
can go to georgewallace.com
georgewallace.net it's a really funny
book and especially right now in our
lives
we need to laugh and who better who
better to take us there than uh than mr
george wallace sir
thank you and when you stop laughing you
stop living
my name is george wallace i love you and
there's absolutely nothing you can do
about it
no i'm gonna get i'm gonna get a lawyer
and fight this thing
i consider you a very good friend of
mine so i always in my shows of talking
to my very best friends
always like to end with your punk ass
hey george thank you so much and take
care no thank you sir let's do it again